Okay, so this person had a long question but it was just stating some of the things that
they're doing and then they said, can we do something about the side effects of dry gums?
This is side effects from radiation. This person was doing radiation on a tumor near their deck.
And the side effects are core damage to the organ.
So dry gums, dry mouth, throat feels dry, uncomfortable.
What do you do with the side effects of that? Well, you really have to look at what's a cause of that.
It's probably radiation affecting the product gland so saliva production is going to be down.
So there, you know, there's not any like perfect answer to this. So the radiation is working.
And it's the tumor is decreasing. Praise God for that.
There's going to be side effects that you're going to have to just deal with.
And it's best ways as possible. So obvious things are trying to drink. I would suggest doing oil in a way that you put like a tablespoon of coconut oil in your mouth.
Let it melt in your mouth because it'll melt instantly in your mouth and swish it around, swish it around, swish it around and spit it out into the toilet and leave that coating of oil of your mouth.
Then two, that can be helpful. So having a kind of a coating of coconut oil on your mouth and on your throat would be beneficial with this when you have a decreased paraden function, you have a decreased saliva function.
There is a product that is that would possibly help with this that is, let me pull it up really quick here.
That is by biotics research. It's called cytoside, cytoside parodid.
And that's by biotics research. I'll put it right down here so you can see it.
cytoside parodid TS because it 180 capsules take about three a day or so that is parodid tissue from a bovine parodid tissue that could help rebuild the chronic gland that's an option.
I would try that too. Can I eat lilies dark chocolate bars? I'd say yes.
But I wouldn't stop doing the radiation if it's working because of the side effects. I would do try to my best to deal with the side effects and continue that.
If they're trying to push you towards chemo 2, I just asked them again, like we talked about last time just continue to try to ask them the tough questions about well, how would this benefit? How do you really think would you tell your your father to do this?
Just be honest with me, I just asked them those kind of tough questions.